Lula quiere mostrarse como un mediador
pero deberá lidiar con las consecuencias
de su cercanía con China y Rusia
Entonces qué países podrían acompañarlo
en esta iniciativa de mediadores para
buscar la paz en Ucrania
buenas noches y gracias por llamar bueno
los países que lo pueden acompañar son
aquellos que tengan ganas de que
efectivamente haya se llega algún tipo
de acuerdo en ese sentido
Lula está
está trabajando bien la idea de Buscar
unir las partes
El problema es que esas partes están muy
separadas muy divididas y cualquier y
hay un clima táctico cualquier cosa que
se diga suena más a favor de a favor de
un de un de un área o de otro de otra en
este caso Lula Esta última declaración
lo aleja o trata de volverlo a la idea
de una acción neutral lo que había
sonado canciones anteriores Y ya cuando
estuvo en China y ya cuando hacía
campaña se lo veía más favorable a este
a Rusia digamos sus declaraciones
terminaban favoreciendo la postura la
postura rusa entonces entonces no es
mala la idea de Buscar países que
acompañen pero el problema es que países
porque Europa occidental está este
totalmente
lista y preparada para continuar para
para defender a Ucrania lo más posible
puede ser Turquía que también quieras
hacer un juego o sea Turquía sí que
tiene una un diálogo como mantiene
diálogo con Rusia también puede ser que
quiera unirse a esa a esa iniciativa
puede pero no no pienso no no creo otros
países sobre todo los del los de la ex
Europa del este que habían estado bajo
dominios soviético que son los que más
están este en contra de esto esto lo que
nos demuestra conflicto tiene que
Tendría que ir madurando hasta llegar a
una posición por las partes de querer
sentarse a dialogar esto es lo que falta
porque lo que hay hasta ahora es que
Ucrania quiere volver a anterior digamos
a la situación previa y con la
devolución de crimea lo cual Rusia no
está dispuesto y putín bueno este con
que mantenga en principio contener estos
en los territorios de la región del
lombas que era parte de la discusión
justamente usted lo estaba mencionando
desde la semana pasada hubo polémica
luego de que Lula se reuniera con y le
pidiera Estados Unidos que dejara de
alentar la guerra en Ucrania Washington
le contesta que está repitiendo como un
loro la propaganda rusa y China sin
tener en cuenta los hechos pero ahora
Lula cambia de tono podemos decir que la
presión lo hizo redireccionar su
discurso
parece que sí
recuerde que hace poco que está Lula en
el poder cien días y creo que a veces
este los líderes no miden el digamos
quiere repetir vieja fórmulas o no No
miden el el impacto de sus palabras como
ya le digo Este es un periodo que es
poco permisivo a a tener posturas muy
muy este
zigzagueantes no entonces hay que ser
cuidadoso porque es mal interpretado por
todas las partes y como Lula tiene su
objetivo principal es bueno es la paz
Pero por otro lado mejorar su situación
económica y e impulsar el desarrollo de
Brasil con la ayuda de China y también
por algunos acuerdos que que está
haciendo últimamente con Rusia Eh bueno
él Busca establecer ese este puente pero
la la el conflicto por este por el
momento es casi prácticamente intratable
no
es muy difícil de acordar justamente con
ese panorama con Lula la cabeza Brasil
es un país confiable para la comunidad
internacional para tomar un papel de
mediador
podría puede ser que sea confiable el
problema es que mire hay una en la en la
ciencia política hay una teoría que se
llama sentarlos a la mesa tiene Brasil
la capacidad de sentar a la mesa a los a
a Rusia y a China y a los Estados Unidos
Aunque abajo y abajo de Ucrania no y
ahora y Europa occidental Me parece que
no todavía no la iniciativa va a tener
que venir de alguien con Mayor Mayor
músculo